ich bin dran und zwar sage ich direkt
wenn ich du wäre würde ich einfach mal
unsere koordinaten in den schreiben was
kathrin regal
da war irgendetwas mag's ein gegner ist
zudem nahm das spiel zu verlassen ist
dann ist es hier
da kommen welche davon welche luca hallo
mein name ist luca herzlich willkommen
hier zu einer weiteren folge micro war
meine damen und herren wir schon jetzt
auf den server kirchen auf der auch
nicht direkt und ich liebe ja wir können
nicht laufen daneben kann ich laufen
okay okay okay du machst unser plan ist
es sind ja zwei leute bei uns das heißt
magst du machst dir direkten work table
habe ich habe ich habe ich hier sitzen
hin
okay ich mache und indirekt eine
spitzhacke und an bauern sonst quasi
direkt weg ok ok macht ganz schnell mal
ganz schnell sie sind nicht da wo sie
sind nicht da ist man ganz schnell es
nicht okay ich mache mich weg max ist
hinter mir cobblestone die sache ist
mist amor game und
ari sein teampartner ist neben uns wir
wissen dass irgendjemand da ist und
deswegen hatten wir in der letzten folge
nicht auslaufen hier noch ein kurzer
ausschnitt ein gegner ist zunahme um das
spiel zu verlassen
mister morris hier gold mines ok gold
gefunden
nehmen wir doch auch ohne als klar
wollen wir das noch und die sozialisten
sichtlich nicht nach getönt ja aber was
bringt das laub ist weil ich dass die da
kommen sie da kommt sagte okay okay wir
sind hinter uns diesen hintergrund all
mein gott oh mein gott max
hast du den granit
wir gehen jetzt einfach noch ganz oben
ganz ganz ganz oben also wir haben einen
dicken vorsprung alles ein kräftiger
aber die sind wahrscheinlich direkt
neben uns
sie waren neben uns okay drop mir mal
bitte nach hinten cobblestone kannst du
das machen
ich kann jetzt gerade nicht weiter
drüber gemacht
das 64 ja ich habe ein bisschen angst
mein spitzhacke sign fünfte weg kann
zwar schon welcher höhe wir sind oder
geändert man sich in die richtung drehe
ich mal nach rechts irgendwie beim
hochbau ok dass wir nicht immer nur die
gleiche richtung ins bauen jetzt erde
hier sehr gut aus mit unserem rennen wie
einfach ich habe gerade schon
irgendwelche back irgendwie den himmel
gesehen kurz
doch so weit ist es nicht mehr leute
also nochmal zusammengefasst die beiden
sind hinter uns und verfolgen uns
wahrscheinlich gerade und sie halte
euro-bonds
wir haben sie auf twitter versucht zu
verarschen so von wegen okay wir sind
jetzt im restaurant essen unserem schiff
war natürlich quatsch wir waren nicht
pizza essen also an alle die das
vielleicht bei twitter gelesen haben am
elfter abends das waren alles schon
ältere bilder und die beiden einfache
frage ich mich gerade den berg rhein max
sekunde wir sind auf 46 alles als normal
ich bräuchte wieder steine locker aber
ganz ganz kurz nur eins liegen ganz
kurzes leben
vielleicht war ich zu wollen ich habe
nicht so viel hast du hast mich stein
nicht gegeben diesem risiko weiter nach
oben weiter nach oben warum du stehst in
den markt weiter nach unglück weiter
nach oben
ich geb dir steine da tijuca bottich
weiter nach oben war da noch um roger
fakt die sind einfach hinter uns was
machen wir
dk wieso sind wir noch nicht oben eine
spitzhacke ist was kaputt
willkommen gibt ja sogar dass er das
gras das gras laub junge läuft love love
love love love love laut ok max wie
viele herzen hasst du wieviel 118 ich
bin voll gepunktet ok laufen laufen
laufen laufen hinterher okay okay ich
sehe sie nicht hinter uns ich sehe sie
nicht hinterherlaufen
ich bin direkt hinter mir hinten etwas
zu essen
gebraten ist nicht okay kommt damit
folgen wir folgen die lupe erfolg mehr
auf dich irgendwo in randbereichen wo
reinwachsen folgt mir ja hast du hast
eine spitzhacke
darauf rein laufen laufen laufen ich
habe werde das ist keine erhältst du
schnell locker
sid gewesen hätte ich weiß aber hier
sind keine namen oder ich sehe keine
nicht runter oh mein gott nicht
entwicklung auf gar keinen fall ins
nicht
doch er da hin oh mein gott oh mein gott
mithin wachse koalition ja sicher ist
sicher setzt es hinter mich irgendwie
wir gehen noch weiter rein aber nur die
haben sie haben dahin werden dahinter
ist namen oder handys name sich zudem
einfach nicht bewegen wurde jetzt
nächsten tag ist richtig ich gucke genau
zu dem namen hin quasi er ich sehe den
namen aber nicht nur jetzt liegt auf
jeden fall oder leute wir haben
eigentlich eine challenge aber chelsea
zu den namen bleibt eine andere richtung
okay nicht gut abbauen nichts machen
einfach kein geräusch und ich weiß wir
sagen nicht wir machen jetzt nichts tue
oh mein gott wenn nicht wäre würde ich
den finger von verschifft ich gehöre
heute leute das war übel spannend gerade
aber unser eigentliche unser
eigentliches taktik bzw
unser job offenbar o ist ja eigentlich
dass wir jede folgende neue challenge
machen
die heutige challenge ist dass wir die
ja nein nicht echallens machen das heißt
das hat sasha grey und sympathisch auf
seinem kanal gemacht diese vier begriffe
darf man nicht sagen
und bei uns ist es so wenn man einen
begriff dieser vier begriffe doch sagt
muss man sich selbst eine backpfeife
geben ja ich weiß nicht das fragen wir
nochmal eine disco truppe nachher nach
von unserer von der wahl von den leuten
hier
ob ich mag's facetime hier runter dann
gleich einblenden darf wenn er leihweise
1 d4 wort hat wörter sagt heger ist
locker hier aus einem schnitt vom video
ich habe ja gerade in der folge gesagt
ich frage nochmal der gruppe nach ob ich
mag seine festen darunter einblenden
darf ich glaube das wäre an sich kein
problem allerdings ist bei max gerade
privat etwas vorgefallen und deswegen
lasse ich jetzt ein bisschen ruhe sage
ich mal und will ihn jetzt nicht all zu
bedenken die irgendwie schneller zu
schneiden bisschen mehr darüber zu
schicken sind dass ich das hier in die
folge reinpacken kann ich hoffe ihr
versteht das jeden halt einfach wenn
maxi eine backpfeife gibt es wirklich
noch sehr häufig passieren sonst kommt
vielleicht heute noch sonst morgen oder
übermorgen auch die folge bei max dort
könnt ihr euch das dann angucken aber
jetzt erst mal noch viel spaß weiterhin
bei vario und last auf jeden fall schon
mal leichter wenn euch das gefällt weil
ich schneide allein jetzt schon an den
ersten sechseinhalb minuten sagt jetzt
gerade schon seit drei vier stunden dran
weiter geht's sonst sieht er das halt
nicht und hört halt nur wie macht sich
eine klatsche gibt und bei mir geht es
dann könntest halt in max partner
schauen aber vielleicht auch eine
facetime eingeblendet also ich würde
sagen ab jetzt einfach oder positiv ich
dachte bereits dass du verkackt hättest
wann ich weiß eigentlich wollen wir die
ganze folge zum chillen
wenn man das nicht sagen darf
allein das worden wenn man so ich glaube
es ist aber unsere eigene hoffen unsere
einzige hoffnung dass wir diese folge
challenges haben weil es ansonsten mitte
die folge jetzt so langweilig nein die
reine okay ich gebe mein klatsche
der stern ist es musik in meinen ohren
alter schwede gehen nicht niemals runter
von disney katze ja ich habe angst
[Musik]
gerade das irgendwo sind dass sie
irgendwo uns liegen
glaubst du diese noch über uns die sind
nicht über uns der name war schon
relativ weit weg ich würd sagen war
durch extra fahren damit ich bestimmtes
jj werk auch gott
[Musik]
was denn ich habe gerade zwei mal zwei
der wörter gesagt deswegen gab ich mir
eine backpfeife also der name die nicht
gesehen habe war locker 100 blogger
entfernt war mir zu groß waren um gern
ich würde am liebsten was essen
ich hab halt nur das hühnchen da kann
man sich ja von vergiften
ich bin gerade damit vergiftet ich würde
sagen wir wagen das jetzt einfach ja
aber ich in dummkopf schon wieder gerade
das jedoch musste bisher noch gar nicht
[Musik]
so bescheuert alter du hast einfach
bisher kein mal gesagt nicht so ich
glaub jetzt sieben mal ist einfach gar
nichts mehr aber ich sag ja auch nicht
so viel gedreht ja nie so viel ich würde
er wirklich sagen luca wir wagen ist
jetzt einfach ist ihr sicher was sollen
wir denn sonst machen
andererseits wenn wir jetzt die ganze
folge abwarten würden bis die bis sie
aus gelockt werden dann verlieren wir
zwar eine folge aber sind nächste folge
wieder sicher weißt du bestimmt damit
aber öffentlich nicht mehr als drei
folgen produzieren oder
der backpfeife wir haben noch gar keine
change fürs nächste mal ich würde sagen
die wagens - eine backpfeife geben
was habe ich gesagt ich hab dich gefragt
die dürfen doch drei nicht mehr als drei
folgen aufnehmen hmm mir eine gegeben
wollen wir wollen wir vielleicht ich bin
ehrlich nicht sicher ich will nicht
riskieren bei weitem noch nicht
schwimmen
du weißt was du gesagt hast was denn wie
heißt die change noch mal sagt den
anfang
[Musik]
vielleicht ist nicht dabei okay nicht
fortgeschrieben lacker ich habe seinen
namen nicht gesehen aber 100% wir uns
irgendwie locken so und ja die anderen
warteten noch dauern
j das j j und das n wort gibt noch die
ganze zeit backpfeifen schon die maxi
sind locker hier irgendwo ja ich glaube
es auch backpfeife ich würde am liebsten
nicht irgendwo hin bauen kann dann kann
ich sagen ich hab zu viel spaß daran an
diesem ganzen challenge zeug und sowas
als dass ich will das jetzt war schon
vor weiß man ja
ich sehe es gibt keine los hab ich schon
gerade religion ein mechaniker jetzt
[Musik]
leider sagte sam noch nicht besitzen
seit elf minuten und wir sagten uns ein
darüber ab dass wir die ganze wörter
sagen
die dass der motorblock
ja da ist name der ausnahme dass name
das name wachsen hieß es ok es nicht
bleiben okay dann haben sie safe
aufgegeben wenn sie jetzt schon über uns
den rücken schießt du sie ja was machen
wir was machen wir über uns ich weiß
aber sie ist ein sneak rumgerannt das
heißt dass sie nicht davon ausgeht dass
wir hier unten sind das was wir machen
wir warten jetzt einfach ab diese
verdammte folge und dann nehmen wir die
comics doch nicht ausloggen ja ach was
wir warten also jemand nudeln
du hast gerade übrig das ja wort gesagt
möglich dass und wieder ins lied ich
frage mich jetzt nur es gibt ja das
plug-in dass man
sich aus sagen kann wenn die in der nähe
sind
stehst du ja wenn die natürlich angesagt
kriegen sie konnte sie kommt sie kommt
die sie geweckt mein gott sie war so nah
alter
was jetzt haus ihr habt sie ab jetzt ist
sie wirklich weg
der name h der name ist soweit gerade
entfernt gewesen dass er quasi dies so
nicht mehr angezeigt wurde
was willst du jetzt noch warten ja
machen machen was machen wir denn jetzt
noch weiter und so folge ist 14 minuten
lang
ich würde sagen 14 minuten wir haben
locker eine minute vorher geredet
glaub wir haben noch zwei minuten ja wir
müssen einfach zwei minuten lang warten
wir müssen einfach zwei minuten abwarten
und hoffen dass mister morgen weiße ball
ist wird er die ganze zeit nur der name
von ari angezeigt dass mister morgen
nicht in der nähe ist und ich würde
sagen wenn da gleich steht
du kannst dich nicht aus das sind gegner
in der nähe
dann bauen wir uns sofort nach unten das
heißt du baust sofort nach unten
nach unten
ja okay wie folgender plant du brauchst
dich nach unten und dann direkt wieder
hoch woanders heißt du dann laufen wir
wieder oben an der an der oberfläche weg
aber dann quasi direkt ab und backpfeife
2 also aber nur ganz gut zusammengepasst
max denn da gleich steht du kannst du
vom server geschickt werden weil leute
in der nähe sind habe ich mich hier nach
unten
drei blöcke dann ganz lang nach vorne
sag ich mal
und dann irgendwo wieder nach oben und
gelaufen da sind die beim vorne waren
sie gerade und habe aufgehört zu fliegen
wo sie kommen auf uns zu
okay die laufende forderung
ok jetzt müssen wir hoffen jetzt müssen
wir hoffen jetzt müssen wir nur beamte
bereit um die nach unten zu bauen und so
weit weg von mir geh weg von max die
beenden ganz kurz die challenge ist
schon okay jetzt entspannt yes yes yes
ja man okay wir haben es geschafft das
war so eng
sorry leute dass wir die ganze folge
land nur unter der erde waren aber das
war an spannung pur wir haben es zwar
als locker genommen mit der challenge
aber die waren die ganze zeit bei uns
quasi aber die beiden denken doch jetzt
locker dass wir ganz woanders sind oder
es ist scheißegal was sie denken weil
sie haben drei folgen aufgenommen haben
zwei aufgenommen wir können jetzt noch
eine aufnehmen machen wir auch und wie
heute wenn das euch gefallen hat last
man like da in der nächsten folge machen
wir dann wieder eine andere stelle
stehen an die luft und kämpfen ein
bisschen keine ahnung was dort auf jeden
fall max vorbeigelegt die seine folgen
wer jetzt die backpfeife gegeben hat
oder jetzt bei mir gesehen mit der
facetime keine ahnung hab ich mal wieder
das war's jetzt hiervon war opa zwei ihr
findet hier noch mal warum hat einst
eingeblendet also die vorherige folge
wenn ihr sehen wollt wie das überhaupt
alles entstanden des videos gefunden
haben und so und hier findet jetzt mal
wie eingebildet wenn ihr daraufhin
könnte meinen kanal ab und automatisch
an einem gewinnspiel teil bei denen eine
playstation 4 gewinnen könnt also
abonniert
ich kann hier die die ware folge
anschauen